[Music]
it is time to take the next step on your
journey I'm not going to be the Dragon
Warrior anymore you will advance the
spiritual leader of The Valley Of Peace
inner
peace inner peace keep your surf off my
bur dinner please dinner with peas in a
sesame so glaze this is not working at
[Music]
all
tyum big
fan once I possess the Kung Fu of every
Master villain no one will dare question
my power not even the Great Dragon
Warrior who's that the most powerful
shape-shifting sorceress the chameleon
how do I find this the chameleon I'm
going to lead you right to her front
door it was against them an
army then we'll just have to get an army
of our
own what is this place the best Crooks
and criminals live here you're a wanted
criminal you sound surprised is it
surprising now you kids be careful of
those
fireworks violence makes our tummies
tingle off why should we help you we
take down the chameleon together being
the Dragon Warrior it's who I
am what do I know about being a
spiritual leader what is it you're
holding a cookie you were chosen to
become something more than you already
[Music]
are how should we do this quick and
painless or slow and painful slow and
painful you finally met your match
chameleon we're not so different you and
I stand back I'm going to kick my
[Music]
butt